Hi, my name is Dillon Tracy.
I think you've had a little touch on the cloud so far. You
might also have a little experience with the cloud.
What is a data science platform in this presentation?  I
would like to talk in a little more detail about what it is and what kind of workflow it will be
.
First of all, how is this data science platform related to other cloud functions provided by
us?
Why do data science in the cloud?  We'll
talk about what you need to do and what its benefits are, and
then use a concrete example to show you what your workflow looks like. The
programming cloud was released in early summer 2014.
This cloud platform focuses on collaborative prototypes or deployment management by deployment teams,
and was released in early fall 2014 with more volumes or online
.  The
data science platform is also part of this portfolio.
The focus here is to import something that is key to data science,
analyze it, and publish the results.
This is a flow. I'll explain this later with a concrete example.
First, there is data.
This data is in a structured or unstructured mono database
. What is contained in the file. It
is updated in real time.
There are many things, such as sexual ones,
which can be imported into the wolfram system for a spectacular interpretation of the data,
which can be customized and visualized in the wolfram language, and
finally the cdf template.
You can create customized and customized documents.
This document can also contain interactive elements that you can present to your organization's decision makers
.
So why do you do data science in the cloud?
The answer is access.  I think it's in ease and reach. I think you've just read a
little about the api function, but the
function is now fluid.
Not only can these be written and executed in a desktop environment, but they can also be deployed in
the cloud and run in the cloud.
For example, yesterday I deployed an api function that returns a map of Italy, but this request is
mine.  It originates from the browser, the calculation is done in the cloud and the response is returned
to the browser. The
browser itself doesn't know or need to know what technology stack is running in the cloud
.
Simply make an http request.  You just do it and get the result.
So you can say that you are democratizing your calculations
20 years ago or even months ago if I handed you the action of the wolfram language
and asked you to do it.  It would
have been an excuse to say I couldn't because I didn't think it was more and more Matty, but
this excuse no longer
works because I can publish what I make as an api function and anyone can
I have a browser, so
the same thing is happening with merchandise documents.
Desktop notebooks with these interactive elements are familiar and
favorite to us, but they are not extensible and can't be configured at all.
It's now possible to use it in a browser as well.
Barrier access is being democratized.
This can solve a huge problem in data science workflows.
There are conversations that are often exchanged at academic societies.
What happened to the person I put together in my notebook
? When I asked how the reaction was at work, my boss got
the answer that I wasn't even wondering. So
cdf's browser plug-in  I
get the answer that the system management department will not let me install it, and I
can only say that it is the case. This is
because such problems have occurred all the time.  I
think it's a big advantage to do data science in the cloud,
so let's actually use the data
This is
a utility bill spreadsheet for my home for a
few years  This is a simple data that summarizes the monthly data over a period of time into a table with 6 columns
, which is stored in a cloud spreadsheet.
Its url is this.
Import this data to the desktop.
This is a new feature of the version store,
but it not only decomposes the file and brings it into the wolfram system, but also tries to recognize the actual situation in the file, that is, it
takes the
raw csv text file and
recognizes the date as the date
left  The yellow box in is that
and recognizes it as a quantity with a quantity unit expressed in dollars
These data 3 s operations have been manual and time consuming,
but are now easy
here  Is returned by the data object, and
here is the dataset object,
which can be queried in various ways.
Here
we extract two columns and use a visualization function to
consume electricity over several years.  Let's take a very simple example of expressing in kilowatts per hour
.
This was done on the desktop. Now switch to the cloud.
This is the front page of the data science platform.
You can get the
data out of a file in the cloud or on the desktop,
or you can get the data out
of url.
Duplicate the workflow in the cloud
Click Import data from url and paste this url here
Then click the continue button and the platform
will create a
notebook This notebook has the code to start the analysis  Includes
This is a regular wait or notebook
Mati or notebook in the cloud You
can do everything you're used to with notebooks here
This is a template notebook
This has extensions  It's like a notebook
where you can place template variables and control their behavior with the buttons above
this template
You can enter whatever you like in the template variables when creating a customized document from the server,
which is useful when creating a custom report at the end of the workflow.
Can be
done in the cloud Visualization with a disk tap is also possible in the cloud
Here you are looking at the same operations you did on the desktop in
the cloud, which is the corresponding cloud  It's a visualization
This isn't a big report, but let's
deploy it for now Press this red deploy button and click on the automation degree report and the
gui will open and here the output format Who sent this report I want to run this report
You can set various things such as time. Assuming that you will
receive a statement of utility bills every month, set this at the end of the month
and click Create.
This will put this template and other things together in the actual state of the child on the server and this sidebar.
You
don't have to wait until the end of the month if you want to do this
in the list of
Is applied and a log file is generated and the resulting document is created
.
This document is archived and sent to everyone listed as the recipient of the document
This is the email.
Click the link in the email and the result will be in the cloud.
This is my report
This is not a big report, but what
if I spend a little more time working to make it look better?
Working on the desktop and uploading templates is also in the cloud.
You
can also work directly on the
interface of
Here is the part that the electric gas company made a mistake.
Here you can see the visualization function, for example the result
histogram of the datelist plot, the following histogram,
etc.  time series model
Predictions made using slightly more complex functions such as fits and time series 4 casts are displayed.
These can be evaluated as if they were a regular notebook, but
deployed as auto-generated reports.  You can make a bigger impact on the viewer
by pressing the create button from this gui You
will see the report you just created in the sidebar
You can also do
this now  I'll show you the result of doing it in advance while waiting.
The pointed part of this orange line is my home.
The pointed part of the blue line is the amount of electricity used in winter. This is 1
Kw consumption and therm usage per hour
This is the sum of the seasonal usage and forecast and the gas and electricity usage,
and this is the forecast for 12 months using the seasonally corrected Salima model.  Is
the forecast for this fall and winter.
It is possible to do various analyzes like this
. You can also compare how well the forecast from last month matches the actual value of this month.
Thus from the beginning to the end of the workflow.  I was
able to create a document that I could present to people. From
raw data to the deployment of the final auto-generated report, the operation is fairly quick and
many reports can be easily created
here.  Switch to the desktop
Here's a little more of what you can do with the icy imported data Here
's a list of good stinking walks into the city of
Champaign  Type
Lists its common names
Also shows the size of the machine and the city where the tree grows. The
city is expressed in chronological order.
This data set is semantically imported.
This time to the interpreter.  The
interpreter tries to assign a tree child to the first column because it hinted that the first
column contains plants. When
this semantic import is finished, we see the raw result of the arched import.
This is done on the desktop and not using the cloud.
Looking at the left column, if you really care about the place and
it is not a vacant lot, the actual situation is returned and this actual situation
Comes with metadata This is a feature that is also used by wolfram alpha
This metadata can be used for a variety
of analyses, facilitating the analysis of so-called knowledge US papers and
also the pair of latitude and longitude values.  Recognized as Respect Roche
and surrounded by salt positions, which makes
mapping easy.
As an example of what is possible with knowledge-based analysis,
if you ask for the number of places where American Hananoki is,
the answer is about 150.
When I asked for the color of the leaves of the American Hananoki,
the answer was green.
Let's do the same thing in the cloud.
This is a template for working in the cloud and uses the same tree data as before.
Tree
Here we will do a little more data science work to find out about the 5 best walks
.
Let's take a closer look at Seiyo Toneriko Let
's narrow down to one of the species and look at the data. If you do the
same
operation of automatic deployment report creation as before, a template report of this tree will be created.  Run
I'll show you the result of the run I did before while I waited for this run to finish
This is the 5 most common
trees in the data Tree child thumbnails come with the metadata for free  It's a thing that accompanies the reality.
You don't need to look into anything special
. It's a characteristic that accompanies the reality. It's free.
This is a color-coded map for each 1 o'clock species of the sample tree.
Where is your current location?  It seems that
there are various functional hands and it is a bit confusing and a little difficult to understand-
When I narrowed this down to the Tonerico shield, it became a little easier to handle.
This is being eaten. This is if it was brought in by sticking to a composer from East Asia called Emerald Ash
Boarer.
Unfortunately, this data does not include data on the damaged gold, so
I made data on the grass.  This simulation is performed.
This is a diseased tree that was simulated based on a two-dimensional distribution. If the diseased tree is
shown in red, the damage is widespread west of Route 57 on this map.
For those who work in the city hall of Champaign,
it would be convenient if such a report was sent by email every Monday. In
another data science course, a machine learning function called Living Phi  I've
also used an example of finding candidates for sick trees in other parts of the town based on the characteristics of the trees
that are actually sick.  If
instrument experts can measure ash borer vulnerable trees based on what they measure with such data, it
will lead to a significant reduction in labor force when the
town owns the number of laps and problems.  The number of experts you can discover is limited,
so this is likely to be an interesting application.
What you've seen in the cloud so far is centered around gui, but we're talking about
language design.  Also emphasizes that in
general you can do the same with languages if you can with gui on the web. Various things that are done
n this auto-generated report cloud are s
rely known in languages for document generation.
Here's a bit from the language level to show you how this is available
Let me show you a very simple template
This is a very simple document template with one slot for the author's name
from the display top  Deploy an auto-generated report
using a template in  You don't even need to set a schedule
Deploy
this It will be bundled and sent to the cloud You
may want the bird to run this without waiting for the schedule once it's uploaded to
the cloud  I haven't set the Jules, so I'll take the run.
There are two ways to do this:
wait for the result to block, or act as if triggered by a natural schedule
and
get an email notification.  There is a non-blocking method of waiting or checking later
.
Here, we will evaluate by blocking method.
Evaluating in Udo
Click on the returned cloud object to see the document generated by this generator
again Return to 0 for utility bills Deploy this from your desktop
without going through the web gui  If you want, you can do it
with just one line of code
like this This is scheduled to be sent monthly
These range templates are very light, for
example here wolfram is a corporate data warehouse  There is a team that manages this and
throws it away for the report to be given, but these processes
are not heavyweight and
some of them are heavy professional photos
so we have a report like this in the morning, for example.
We're still developing it so that we can deploy 10 of them and send them to different people in slightly different ways.
Here we'll tell you to do this asynchronously. A
little more complicated example.  Here
's a template for a report on stocks I think
it's easier to see what you can do with this template
I'll
give you a lot of tickers for this
stock report  Give the report a list of desired tickers and the template
will use Financial Data Night Red to check the characteristics of these testimonies and
change the interactive widget to explore these characteristics as a special time series over the last n days.
Better yet, this takes advantage of the template's ability to repeat blocks, which allows the template to handle a variety of household elements, so you can give
this template one, five,
or even 50 securities.
I'm working for a financial company and someone
asked me to make a daily report of the performance of the last 30 days on the stocks of the 5 companies with the highest trading volume yesterday in the trucking industry.  You
usually don't know what characteristics you'll be reporting until that day,
so here's what the document generator
should give to the template generator when the document is being generated a bit smarter.  You
have to be able to determine if it should be  We
'll call this driver logic.
Driver logic can be used in inline code, in its own scripts, or even in its
own notebooks. Here we put it in our own function and this
driver-
tracks using financial data.  About members of the transportation industry
Check yesterday's volume, organize it, pick its tops and then
prepare to fill other slots in the template
The actual deployment of the document generator itself is fairly straightforward
and specifies the template schedule driver logic.
Just deploy and
run this It takes a few minutes to complete as it uses a lot of data pufflets
This
fits into this import analysis presentation paradigm in the data science platform workflow
Everyone in this session
You saw how the
arched interpretation streamlined some of the analysis and made it possible to do things that weren't possible
before. Doing data science in the cloud.  This can solve the timeless problem In
my experience, this timeless problem was
the biggest obstacle to getting wolfram staff into the data science organization, although the
cloud can be used alone.
It's also very easy to use in combination with a desktop, making cloud deployments easier to handle. Even
those who
are currently doing data science without the cloud
have a model of what's happening in memory and on disk.
I think that this is an operation with a long wait time and it is judged that this is a short operation etc. If
you use the cloud, you will add another thing to this In other
words, it is happening in the cloud  You can also make a distinction between things and what's happening locally, but
this is basically the same idea and the
platform allows you to work in both modes
.  I couldn't show it, but if you are interested, I can explain it in more detail.
Please ask in the question and answer session after the conference
. Thank you for your attention.